ma'am I am here to help you have nothing
to worry about
what says yes you package yesterday are
you sure you're right I'm stupid
yep I should go back to my country I II
met Brooke right now I need your help
lunch isn't until 12 a.m. I'm sorry
static shock did you hear mr. Darrow we
have a meeting yep
I'm gonna go I'll be at the meeting I'm
coming yes I guess we'll run in the
meeting yeah come on to the meeting to
get it that's you me I horns oh I'm
gonna finish watching this porn and then
I'll go to the meeting okay yep gotta
get the evil out you know I guess I'll
see you at the meeting I'm gonna finish
this and then I'll be in the meeting
I'll fetch it your hands down you guys
swim and paint me for the last game
that's my wings of want me to take
the training the bus to the no right now
are you joining us or do I need to beat
that ass again
[Music]
hey so Luke tell us how it all went down
but believe it or not I didn't have
anything to do with this one the night
pigeon heroically defended this was that
that's the night pigeon
he's captain United's sidekick well I
wouldn't say a psychic per se I mean he
does his own solo missions every minute
why have I never heard of him probably
because he named himself after a big rat
bird huh let's get to business actually
the pigeon is a very intelligent smart
animal I didn't come here to talk about
aquatic creatures okay I came here to
talk about one thing you're all getting
you take over I'm gonna go fire to
people who can't pronounce library
hahaha where are we lost package
complaints are up 15% from last month
beautiful you got that address
sorry what is this
you must be the new guy it's the perks
program you give me the address of a New
York shipment over $800 and I give you a
cash bonus 100 bucks
what about the customer what's this
guy's deal 93 seconds left on your break
enjoy it this feels weird
I don't like this who cares just shut up
do his ass get paid don't ruin this for
us
[Music]
oh
they killed Captain United only night
vision had been there
it's Prairie be our backup your desk
you